[Music]
you know guys it seems like just
yesterday the overwatch league was first
formed but after four stages 23 weeks
and 91 days I think it's safe to say the
first ever o WL season was a smashing
success except for the 140 Shanghai
dragons thing but anyways with the
London Spitfire being your first ever
champions we thought it would be the
perfect time to take a look back and
give you the top 10 plays from Oh w-well
season 1
kicking off our list at number 10 is New
York Excelsior's libero who goes on an
absolute tear on Genji as he slices and
dices his way through not one but four
sole dynasty players to fend off the
oncoming siege
[Music]
because I'm so behind the optimal target
area
nothing gets you going like a good man I
play it we haven't seen many lately but
LeBron delivers known as one of the
world's best battle Mercy's our number 9
place sees Neptuno prove that mercy can
do more than just save your team's bacon
with no dps in sight Neptuno took
matters into his own hands and proceeded
to wipe out three outlaws players all
while raising two of his teammates just
for good measure the kill on Jake while
he was channeling that ability the
caduceus blast the paying off quite well
and now over the points a bit of a dosey
doe at the houston outlaws though they
come out of eatin in front for now I'm
gonna be the goose legs is gonna be very
careful make sure it gets another
killing the battle bear see what is
going on the chili will it be the
difference though remains to be seen
couple big hilsa members coming in at
number eight is the LA gladiators Fisher
on King's row who lands an absolutely
disgusting form an earth shatter
before following it up with a triple
collapse fire strike to completely wipe
the floor to mayhem
Kamiya big goose brings him back up
first shatter comes through all bold the
tanks knockdown
we'll kill with a fire strike for a
vendor this fight was so disgusting the
gladiators are going to need to rename
themselves the aristocrats if there's
one thing to take away from our number
seven play it's that if at first you
don't succeed try try again with the
game headed into overtime Dallas's OG
doesn't let a blocked earth shatter keep
him down as he recharges his ultimate in
record time to pull off one of the
fastest earth shatters you'll ever see
before capping it off with a 3k of his
own straight throwing it out there from
og now waiting for the combo his shatter
gets denied completely by the shield he
will succeed to take it up for a ride
though faith gets caught in the corner
it leaps back the safeties we lose green
however in the meantime and faith bench
oh gee another shutdown for the defense
before at the summer thinking okay
what's the so cheesy fragrant don't
really too short because the team just
wasn't there but now that they're
clearly firing on all cylinders oh gee
just seemed like one of the better tanks
sneaking in at number six is New York
Excelsior's pine who slips behind enemy
lines to pull up a series of gutsy plays
to delete for Spitfire players with
flicks so filthy he'll have to watch
them twice as you're about to see with
the m4 sight and nailed the shots not
many widow-makers would go for this play
jumping in at number five is yet another
play from Fisher who says who needs hit
scan as he falls through the air with
primal rage to maul the deadly airborne
duo known as farmer C now can we just
all take a minute to appreciate this
man's determination you killed you're
going in favor the gladiators in another
half tried to come through for vibration
on new utilities we know how devastating
we got another job he just got back my
Rajan
[Applause]
number four on our list comes courtesy
of one of the best macri's in the game
big boss pine facing off against the
houston outlaws on illios pine shows off
his pinpoint accuracy as he pops off
with a ridiculous 5k that only a big
boss can pull off here comes pine gets
one gets two looking for a bit more it
gets another one are you kidding me this
guy is gonna single-handedly change the
point back over that started so well for
Houston - they forced the early rez on
to Joe knock pine already with the
Deadeye to start off this map coming in
at number three on our list is
Philadelphia fusions carpe who shows us
that he can in fact do it all as he
wipes out four members of the Boston
uprising with some crispy head shots to
retake the point and win the map bounce
on high crowds to escape - to get jumped
on but it looks like the Boston uprising
you're too busy trying to take the point
the widow dual one again Philadelphia
fuchsia go and try to come out on top
strike it though
triple the barrage there the graviton
helping both supports accord together
put they need a baton face I don't know
what to say that is just incredible
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
a 2000 i q-- team play for the ages a
team play that will go down as one of
the best to ever be seen it's the LA
gladiators surprising everyone on day
one of the owlplz sit back relax and
enjoy the show socially they go towards
the poi you're gonna be able to keep
everybody up as well
I look still trailing this eye here I
feel like more recently we're not asking
what silk thread can't do anymore or I'm
kind of asking what he can't so many
different euros that he can sort of
bring out closet was very effective
okay I like this to the Gladius this is
the stood in a train circle around the
Spitfire what interruptus a little bit
here where are you going
where all this is so not cool Gillian
small so he's waiting here we can sort
of walk out what I'll try doing I think
he's gonna either he's gonna either
switch to Widowmaker
the best-laid plans fail but not this
one big planks from the gladiators and
they let loose the widow at just the
right time in the overwatch leagues
first ever grand final London Spitfires
profit shows us just why he is the best
damn DPS in the world with 23 seconds
left on the clock profit cuts through
the fusions defenses like a knife
through butter single-handedly deleting
five players to go on and eventually win
the inaugural season of owm
for the fusion father killed
[Applause]
just clutching by that poco to k.will us
the the ERISA ultimate as well and
they're just able to do it but profit
man what did he do this here
what was this entire clips nuts honestly
if one feed five stubble songs best way
to get your best play of the game by far
our best play of the match
alright guys that's our list now if you
like this video let us know in the
comments and we might just give you
another one sorry there's dj khaled
reference all I'll stop now thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button
[Music]